merci à lui et félicitations donc on va
se projeter un petit peu au 8 juin à
présent avec un triathlon duo c'est à la
fois pour les valides et les personnes
en situation de handicap exactement
Wilfried ce week-end Versailles
accueille la troisième édition de ce
triathlon national en duo c'est du
handisport ou les équipes sont composées
comme vous le disiez d'invalides et d'un
non valide le valide est un guide et la
tête non valide et surtout non voyant ou
malvoyants dans cette dans cette épreuve
nous avons suivi d'ailleurs une équipe
yvelinoise à l'entraînement avec Elodie
moine
malvoyante depuis l'âge de 15 ans
Dominique Boucheron perd la vue il y a
deux ans cette sportive accomplie doit
alors adapter sa passion à son handicap
le vélo se transforme en tandem et la
course est menée par un guide Dominique
et Laurent se sont rencontrés il y a un
an et demi grâce à l'association
Valentin oui pour être efficace et
performant sur le parcours du triathlon
il ne doit faire qu'un alors la
confiance elle est primordiale
oui ça c'est ça c'est primordial et oui
fatalement après on s'entend plus ou
moins bien avec certains pilotes mais
après
au bout d'un moment on roule avec les
pilotes avec qui on s'entend bien et
avec Laurent oui on rigole bien on a une
super complicité
Laurent le guide pratique le triathlon
depuis trois ans à Versailles il va
prendre part à son premier triathlon
handisport ou la nage est remplacée par
le canoë-kayak je me suis rendu compte
que c'était plus facile de trouver cette
osmose avec un équipier une équipe
pierre malvoyante ou non voyante parce
que le handicap nous oblige à nous
pilote et voyons à décrire les choses
différemment à parler davantage la
communiquer plus avec son équipier donc
finalement c'est une vraie richesse et
on apprend plus vite au-delà de la
performance sportive c'est le moment de
complicité qui réunit ce duo on aborde
pas le triathlon du haut dans l'objectif
de faire un résultat avec une logique de
performance et surtout une l'objectif de
partager quelque chose entre équipiers
et puis avec les gens qui vont
participer à cet événement dans le
handisport le pilote est souvent
l'athlète de l'ombre mais pas au
triathlon en duo
non il y a pas de méritant on fait du
sport voilà moi je peux pas faire du
sport toute seule donc je dirais que le
pil ote est méritant de de consacrer du
temps pour nous
il n'y a pas de pour moi il y a pas de
méritant s'il y a des sportifs c'est
tout une cinquantaine d'équipes seront
présentes à la troisième édition du
triathlon national en duo château de
Versailles Dominique Boucheron ne
participera pas à la compétition avec
Laurent mais avec un pilote qu'elle ne
connaît pas encore elle devra s'adapter
très rapidement comme au quotidien
allez on est sur orbite là ça y est le
triathlon duo ce sera des 8h30 le samedi
8 juin on va continuer d'en parler
encore quelques instants avec l'un des
organisateurs qui est en ligne avec nous
oui Olivier joue de la jocelinière
chargé des sports au niveau national
pour l'association Valentin à Huy
bonsoir à vous
bonsoir tout le monde alors
expliquez-nous un petit peu pour ce
triathlon duo est-ce que l'organisation
du d'une compétition de ce type est un
peu différente en termes de structure de
repérage de parcours par exemple
de parcours il y a un parcours qui est
pas mal banalisé puisqu'il s'agit de
trois épreuves autour du canal du
château de Versailles donc la première
est un jogging de 6 km autour du canal
la deuxième épreuve est très en tandem
de 12 km dans le parc et la troisième
épreuve est une épreuve de canoë-kayak
ça n'a pas le droit de se baigner dans
le canal
d'environ un kilomètre une donc si vous
voulez le notre objectif c'est
d'associer un déficient visuel avec un
guide et donc nous avons pratiquement 5
ans ça nous avons 55 équipages minimum
qui vont concourir donc samedi matin
dans le cas de fossiles du château de
Versailles mais alors la disparition de
l'épreuve justement de natation et
spécifique à Versailles en fait
canoë-kai l'avantage juste à cause de
disparition de se baigner effectivement
elle est spécifique à Versailles mais
dans la mesure où c'est la troisième
édition que nous faisons dans dans ce
cadre merveilleux bah on n'a jamais fait
d'autres choses que l'épreuve de
canoë-kayak en partenariat avec la
Fédération Française de canoë-kayak qui
nous aide et alors vous parlez de choses
spécifiques par rapport à une une
compétition de triathlon normale
effectivement ce sont des déficients
visuels donc ça implique un guide la
confiance du guide à la fois dans dans
le tandem dans le canoë-kayak courir
avec quelqu'un de kilomètres c'est pas
évident non plus donc tout ça c'est basé
à la fois sur la une grande confiance
entre les les deux entre le binôme ce
sont des binômes qui les deux personnes
du binôme se connaissaient déjà c'est
vous qui les avez constitués ces équipes
alors j'irai pour 60 ou 80% ce sont des
binômes qui viennent de toute la France
donc ils se connaissent et qui ont qui
se sont entraînés pour cette épreuve et
puis quelques quelques uns des
non-voyants qui n'ont pas de guide donc
là on leur met un guide on leur propose
de remettre un guide et ils vont ils ont
la possibilité de s'entraîner vendredi
après-midi la veille de l'épreuve et
puis sinon bah ils font connaissance
pendant des crèmes
la deuxième chose qui est quand même
très originale dans ce triathlon en duo
c'est que nous faisons un partenariat
donc avec le château de Versailles après
les épreuves sportives un pique-nique et
la remise des trophées et ensuite visite
tactile du château de Versailles
invisible
et sportif et alors le plus important
aussi au delà de la performance sportive
on a rencontré évidemment ce week-end
une équipe idéinoise c'est peut-être ce
moment de partage qui est spécifique au
triathlon du haut non
au sein des équipes
effectivement c'est c'est dans c'est
intense et beaucoup d'émotions et c'est
effectivement une véritable complicité
entre entre le déficient visuel et puis
son vide et c'est vraiment on peut pas
rester insensible quand on les voit ça à
l'épreuve et qu'on les voit monter sur
le podium très bien merci beaucoup
Olivier on suivra ça de près ce week-end
donc rendez-vous 8h30 pour le départ de
ce triathlon national
dans le château de Versailles on parle
du château côté Grand Trianon pour
assister donc à cette épreuve de
triathlon en duo valide et nous valide
ensemble réunies autour du sport un
moment de partage vous l'avez mentionné
tout à l'heure Anthony le 7 8 sport à
présent se poursuit avec quelques
résultats
un peu plus d'un mois du départ du Tour
de France l'organisation de la dernière
étape se peau fine tout simplement
évidemment elle partira à deux
Versailles pour ensuite traverser 50 ans
en Yvelines avant de rejoindre les
Champs-Élysées de nuit cette fois-ci
nous avons rencontré Anne Lepage membre
de la direction des sports de la
communauté d'agglomération de 50 ans en
Yvelines qui n'espère pas énormément de
retomber touristiques avec le passage de
cette étape on l'écoute cette année
parce que c'est la santé méditation du
tour elle part en fin de journée et puis
c'est plus du spectacle l'enjeu sportif
aura eu lieu sur les étapes qui
précèdent là on va avoir des coureurs
qui seront un peu plus détendus et qui
passeront chez nous par Guyancourt
Montigny Bretonneux voisins de
Bretonneux et Manille et hameaux c'est
pas une étape qui est très spectaculaire
la partie spectaculaire pardon sera
plutôt l'arrivée sur les Champs-Élysées
ou là il y a des boucles qui vont être
faits par les coureurs donc je pense que
le plus gros des touristes se
concentreront sur cette zone après par
contre c'est une chance pour nous pour
notre population de pouvoir se mettre au
bord des routes et
et encourager ses coureurs en football
pour le compte de la 26e et dernier
journée du championnat de division
d'honneur Versailles se déplaçait à
Issy-les-Moulineaux et c'est incliné un
quatre buzza 2 longtemps sur le podium
cette saison les Yvelines noires ont un
peu craqué dans les derniers matchs et
termine Thala 6e place dans la poule B
de promotion d'honneur que l'on voit
s'afficher trap c'est incliné à
Porcheville 2-1 pour le compte de la 22e
journée les Trappistes terminent 3e
cette saison de son côté dans la poule
seguyencourt à concéder le match nul à
domicile face à Aubervilliers et termine
cet exercice 2012 2013 à une anonyme 7e
place après avoir outrageusement dominé
la phase allée en football féminin et
l'encours déjà champion depuis plusieurs
semaines a concéder le match nul de deux
face à Poissy les Amazones infinissent
tranquillement en roue libre mais
toujours invaincu cette saison du tennis
également Anthony je coupe dans votre
élan on passe du football au tennis pour
parler des compétitions qui se déroulent
en marge de Roland Garros oui il y en a
quand même hein quatrième journée de
Nationale 3 matchs par équipe homme
plaisir à arracher la victoire à Yutz
d'autres matchs à trois les plaisirs
rois sont désormais deuxième de leurs
poules et c'est où ça y est très bonne
question la réponse j'avais cherché un
autre nom parce que je savais que vous
allez me la poser
bien lourd à Gayou une défaite cinglante
8 matchs à zéro les imminois sont
toujours 5e de leur poule chez les
femmes plaisirs en National 4 c'est
incliné à domicile 4 3 face au tennis
club je compte bien et c'est où ça le
Tennis Club je conviens
la prochaine fois vous me donnerez pas
vos fiches comme ça j'aurai pas les
réponses avec on passe au basket à
présent avec des nouvelles de ces
joueuses du Chesnay Versailles l'entente
elles étaient avec nous la semaine
dernière et on va voir un peu comment ça
s'est passé pour elle dernière journée
des playoffs 10e journée exactement de
Nationale 2 l'entente le chêne
Versailles se déplacer au Creusot
malheureusement les joueuses de vinco
bardeach se sont inclinés 68 à 64
peut-être elles avaient déjà un peu à la
tête à la finale de du championnat de
France de National 2 qui se déroule à
tour ce weekend c'est ce qu'elle nous
avait dit effectivement la semaine
dernière elles sont bien concentrées sur
finale sport américain toujours du
baseball 7e journée de Division 2
Montigny se déplaçait ce dimanche sur le
terrain des squale de Vauréal dans le
Val-d'Oise partage des points entre le
deux équipes un premier match du matin
remporté 12,8 par les squats et
l'après-midi les joueurs d'Arnaud faux
se reprennent et gagne de justesse la
seconde main la seconde manche 12
secondes
inconforte lors de deuxième place
derrière Chartres avec 9 victoires et 5
défaites et après c'est résultat
quelques informations pour conclure oui
tout d'abord un bravo à Alan Brachet le
jeune triathlète du club de 50 ans en
Yvelines a décroché le titre de champion
de France minime on le voit en photo ici
ce week-end le jeune 58 mois réalise une
saison exceptionnelle puisque après son
titre national en dû attelant en avril
du côté du hockey sur gazon
Saint-Germain-en-Laye a remporté la
finale du championnat de France de
hockey sur gazon d'ailleurs face à l'île
ce week-end les saint-germain-nois se
sont imposés très difficiles
et en ont ainsi repris leur revanche sur
la finale de l'an passé et remporte là
leur cinquième titre de champion de
France les deux clubs valident aussi
leur ticket pour la la prochaine Coupe
d'Europe et concernant l'équipe de
France qui compte parmi ces rando
nombreux saint-germain-nois que nous
avions suivi il y a quelques semaines et
bien les Bleus se sont qualifiés pour la
prochaine étape de la World League c'est
c'est mange deux Coupes du monde pour
eux allez vers les Jeux olympiques de
Rio 2016 et enfin une toute petite info
concernant l'OSC Élancourt le club de
football et bien ils organisent ce
weekend des détections pour ces équipes
féminines jeunes et seniors et pour les
équipes jeunes garçons aussi rendez vous
pour les intéressés au stade d'y
Boniface à partir de 14h merci Anthony
pour cette édition complète du 7 8 sport
on vous retrouve lundi prochain et la
réponse à cette question où se trouve
Yutz on essaiera de trouver en attendant
vous pouvez évidemment commenter sur
cette suite sport sur Twitter et les
réseaux sociaux à lundi prochain bonne
soirée